oh
it's all green screen really
this is all in camera done practically
it's an old photography trick
what's up everyone we are here today to
bring you a new visual effects episode
we got the original three back on the
couch again today it's been a little
while since the three of us were
together and i'm happy to be here with
you guys we're gonna be looking at some
cool effects some wonky effects some
awful physics so flip that setting to 4k
and hit the pause button to let it
buffer because we're about to jump in
let's get dirty
all right you guys want a surprise wait
what movie is this this is charlie's
angels full throttle it's a fun bad
movie i've spotted hammers i'm on them
red bike red helmet check out my beach
bod
this guy doesn't care wait a minute i
know that guy that's that's the dude
from 300 he's the king leonidas
no not king no the the god king xerxes
xerxes that's xerxes what no hold on
that's totally xerxes hold on hold on
hold on hold on hold on
wait nico is that legit
i'm looking it up right now put a nose
ring on him and connect it to his
earlobe and then
oh that's definitely xerxes how did you
recognize him this is what he looks like
he doesn't look like king xerxes
[Music]
they're trying to like blend between the
actual shot and the green screen shot
[Music]
[Laughter]
all right the sky right the sky looks
really weird it's like there's this
weird like neon edges to it and stuff
chances are it was a really hazy day
especially they're like filming around
los angeles here so even if this guy's
being exposed well they're using good
cameras it's still gonna kind of look
white they want that crisp blue vibrant
color basically what they're doing here
is in color grading they are basically
just eye dropping the really bright
slightly blue object which is the sky
getting a color key out of it and
cranking that saturation and the tint to
be as blue as possible but the thing is
you're basically pulling a color key
you're basically doing like a blue
screen using the sky and you can see how
rough the edges are of that quote
unquote blue screen with that white
fringing you can see this in some of our
videos when i color grade them and i try
to pull the sky down if you look closely
for some older videos you'll see that
fringing
wait hold on hold on what did i do
what did i just miss what did i just
miss wow
all right so what's gonna happen to
xerxes oh
it just gets so ridiculous
[Music]
[Applause]
he's dead
it's shia
what
wow
wow
what's going on clint you have you have
something you want to show us right all
right so we just checked out a
groundbreaking movie wait what let's
take it all the way back let's go all
the way back to 2001
uh the stanley kubrick 2001. let's go
all the way back and see what kind of
stuff he was getting into in 1968 i
think
this is the thing that has always blown
me away most about this movie is the
fact that this movie came out a year
before they landed on the moon it's
mind-blowing
[Music]
dude yeah look at that floating pin this
is not an element 3d andrew kramer vfx
element here this is actually a pen
floating in 3d space and then she grabs
it
it's there like there's no visual
effects going on here you guys actually
recreated this effect in one of your
half-life videos right the gravity gun
whereas we've renamed it recently
half-life alex the movie
it's the same way that stanley kubrick
did it right
the reason we had to use the same
technique is because it's a glass bottle
so we can't really put it on a green
screen and it has liquid in it back then
especially like fluid simulations
weren't that easy on a home computer
yeah so we want to have realistic
looking fluid in a glass object so we
can't do it with cg so the way we did it
is the same way kubrick did it back in
1968 basically you just take a giant
sheet of glass or plexiglas something
that is perfectly see-through and clear
and you glue it very lightly to that
glass so you can't see any of the glass
you can't even see the glue you have two
people holding the glass floating in
front of the
lens but you got to make sure that glass
is clean
like super clean this is a pretty big
sheet of glass here and it's only
getting larger as we zoom out oh my god
you're right i didn't even think about
that and that pen
is not close to the lens yeah that's
huge that's a huge piece of glass it has
to be yeah very well done just the tiny
little trick visual trick that they did
here on 2001 and we're just getting
started
[Music]
you guys saw inception right you
remember the rotating hallway they
basically built a rotating set for the
space station and it's such an
incredible effect how is the key are you
wait are you saying the camera is static
right here in that shot he's following
him yeah it's mounted to the center
point now there the camera is straight
up mounted to the frame of the whole
building yes so another thing that this
movie doesn't account for at all with
this whole like rotating thing is that
yes technically you would be stuck to
the ground with gravity but it would
have to be spinning so fast that that
small radius that
you would feel sick in there because the
weight difference between your toes and
your head would be different you'd be
disoriented i think it's the coriolis
effect
why are you looking at us
i do know this though i went on that one
space ride at epcot and that's basically
this but just maxed out now have you
tried standing off of the wall while
it's doing that
[Music]
so guys honestly if you've ever you know
ran around a rotunda like this in outer
space let me know what you thought you
felt from your inner ear and how it
affected you uh on your last space
travel yeah let's talk about the final
moment of this movie the the traveling
through time the warp speed effect
[Music]
all the crazy like light effects going
on there is done in camera right yes all
in camera no visual effects no andrew
kramer this is all in camera done
practically basically what you're doing
is it's an old photography trick
basically they set up a giant black
cloth and they cut a slit through the
center they had the camera on a dolly
and they would dolly up to that slit
behind that slit behind that piece of
cloth with the cut through it there was
just a bunch of colorful imagery that
they would slide from left to right and
when the camera stays open the shutter
speed stays open for a long amount of
time as the camera is dollying in you're
getting this weird warpy effect it took
a five minute exposure per frame twice
because you had to do the left side and
then the right per frame on that one
frame so it's ten minutes to get one
frame and there's 24 frames per second
so it's like 120 minutes it was like two
hours
per second of this sequence
two hours of time to create one second
of footage a month-long process to make
it oh at least it was probably several
months
at the end there's a moment where
basically you start to see these nebulas
and start to expand outwards and it
looks like you know galaxies are being
formed kubrick was experimenting with
the idea of dropping ink into his coffee
as a test he shot
super macro footage of the ink dripping
into his coffee and you get something
very very similar to this and it's
completely random when you drop it in
you do one drop two drop and it just
expands and opens up and you film it in
slow mo
this is like that's exactly what gavin
from the slimming guys has done like
several times really he's like dropping
ink droplets into water and just seeing
it like billow out in slow-mo douglas
trouble said he worked on this movie for
two and a half years there's a whole
bunch more to talk about in 2001 so
we'll definitely touch on it in the
future so subscribe if you guys aren't
already hit the bell notification don't
miss a single thing because we got a lot
of stuff for you guys
wow that's awesome oh yeah where's his
head where would his real head be yeah
right
right what dude because of the way his
head lands in real life it was like a
bit of a forced perspective thing he's
actually landing way to the left of the
urinal there but in the final scene they
actually stretched it up to line it up
better so that whole side wall there
it's not as it was originally filmed
they make it look like he's colliding
with the toilet when reality in the
actual physical thing he's ahead of it
it's the same trick behind lieutenant
dan's legs when he's spinning around and
they have that table in the way so the
subtle demonstrations of like oh his
legs are short he here they are passing
through something that if it was just an
actor with real legs they would hit the
thing so with the wall when his neck
lands up right against the wall it's the
same subtle like no we're gonna really
sell that somehow we've removed that
object from space
so look at the blood coming out of that
neck there look at that neck
look at that neck dude look at that neck
snap so that shot there was just like
the head and the bloods pouring out of
the neck i at first assumed it was just
like a regular fluid simulation but they
actually filmed that practically so cool
yeah actual real liquid coming out of
this like stump that they made and they
just tracked it onto uh his real neck
they didn't even have to put like a
green screen head on him that's
ingenious because the lighting matches
the fluids like the fluid dynamics are
perfect like to do a fluid simulation
like that be kind of a pain in the butt
[Music]
oh that's so jackie chan dude
i'm pretty sure this was brad allen brad
allen was jackie chan's right-hand man
on the jackie chan stunt team and then
went on to do kingsman and
what's this movie called
[Music]
dude
people lost it in theaters when that
happened it's all green screen really
they actually filmed it practically
against a green screen and come them
into the shot so it's two different
elements merged together to make them
look like one person it's just good
tracking clever compositing that mirror
reflection someone had to film the back
side of him kind of do something like
that and then comp that onto the mirror
that's like a subtle work that it would
look really weird if it wasn't there
that was awesome i i mean edgar wright
is just a genius when it comes to
combining practical and visual and in
storytelling in every way i think he's a
genius i think he's a master director
like he knows how to tell a story using
really efficient storytelling methods we
we need groups we need more groups all
right okay we're going to be looking at
gi joe rise of the cobra specifically
this ending sequence there's this whole
like military base under the arctic ice
the bad guy layer and i'm not really
criticizing the effects as much as the
decision processes that went into making
this sequence because just watch it just
watch it
the ice is falling down
they broke it and some of the ice lost
its buoyancy properties
it fell down to sink to the bottom the
ocean where we store all of our ice on
the bottom of the ocean i'm sure all of
the visual effects artists working on
this were like but
that's not how ice works it's like too
late we shot it make it happen also
notice how all of the explosions are
acting as if they're in the atmosphere
rather than underwater yeah there's
smoke
oh my god
smoke doesn't move that way yeah like
the way it's plumbing outwards is you
have to require yeah it turns into
bubbles it's underwater so yeah this
this is uh not bad visual effects this
is bad writing the reason why i wanted
to bring this up is because all of you
visual effects artists who worked on
this movie
i apologize that you had to go through
that thank you for your service
[Music]
guys we have been working for months on
tactical reloads
it's the third one
instead of us reacting to things why
don't you go over there and you react to
it leave a comment telling us what you
think it's freaking sweet we spent all
this time doing vfx on it go check it
out it's live right now on the corridor
youtube channel
if you would like to see these episodes
early consider subscribing to our
website corridor digital.com we got all
these episodes and cool exclusive shows
plus the vlogs with no ads higher
quality than youtube and a whole bunch
of other great stuff go check it out if
you haven't corridor digital.com
yeah
pp